More recently, I did have a hate account on Instagram. They, um,
like told me to kill myself and told me that I like was ugly and I looked like a
clown, but then I realized they're only making fun of me because I'm giving them
attention about it.
[Inaudible].
I'm a pro social media because I like to send meme. So my grandma,
I like to keep connected with my friends. But most importantly,
I think it's a useful platform and tool.
I didn't know what a trans guy was before I was on tech talk.
I just thought it was like a masculine girl.
Of social media, but like, I don't use them.
I kind of just have enough posts that doesn't make me seem like a loser
Really toxic because everything's based off numbers.
I just want to see how it pro social media has helped their life because it
hasn't really helped me as a person.
I'm a content creator on talk Instagram, Snapchat.
I would say that I would make like 30 to $40,000 a month.
I'm anti-social media because of the present algorithms.
Yeah.
No,
I think Tik TOK is because it's manipulating their users and taking so much
information from them. And they're showing that through the,
for you page and people.
I don't care.
[inaudible].
Hi, I'm Alexa,
I'm 18 years old and I'm pro social media and I love social media just because
of the culture it brings.
Hi, I'm Phillips plural.
I am on the pro side and I just like to spread awareness.
I'm Alex, I'm 16.
I'm on Instagram tech talk and a little bit of YouTube and I am pro social media
because it helped me meet a lot of other trans kids when I was struggling.
Hi, I'm Ella,
I'm 15 and I'm anti-social media because I find it really toxic and competitive
for myself. Hi, I'm Emma, I'm 18 and I am anti-social media.
And I'm the CEO of a movement that works to kind of promote a healthier
existence on social media. My name.
Ms. Emmy I'm 16 I'm anti-social media because of personal
experience and like general things.
Social
media.
I definitely find myself scrolling for hours when I'm bored and I definitely get
sucked in and I can't stop.
For me. Um, a lot of my school stuff got pushed to media, although.
Clubs and orgs. Another one that's more personal than me is that, um,
keeps you in touch with your family. All my family's in Vietnam. So yeah. Yeah.
And a lot of my friends are on it.
Um, just like on their accounts, you know,
like hyping them up or just like texting them on Instagram. Cause I don't,
I don't like to use it.
It's definitely my number one source of entertainment.
I don't watch as much YouTube or Netflix and I kind of just go through tick talk
and like that's what brings me joy sometimes. Yeah. Yeah.
Short attention spans. Oh yeah.
You get sucked in like you go on for like 30 minutes and then you're just there
forever. And that happens to me all the time,
but sometime I spend more time comparing myself to others. Oh,
I'm not getting that many likes and it kind of brings me down. But um,
if I went on to talk and I kind of just analyzed everyone and just was like
trying to compare myself, then it would definitely bring me down.
But just as a content creator, I just have the mindset of like, Oh,
this is what you make. And maybe I can make it differently.
Prior to a movement. I started called logoff.
I spent about five hours on social media day and it was to talk with my sister
who was in college, but I also got really bad repercussions about my body.
And I felt really terrible after scrolling. But you know,
after I rethought about how I wanted to spend my time on there,
it became much more productive. So I still spend time on like Instagram.
It's just to like get a meme from my college sister or to like talk with friends
that really bring me up. I have.
I have an Instagram, I have a Tech-Talk,
but like I never opened the app like ever I'm clearly not the skinniest.
And like I have alopecia, so I'm losing my hair and like,
I'll look on social media and like,
I'll see some like K-pop star and they're like a double zero with the longest
hair on the planet. And they're like, see like their skin is silk smooth.
And when I take pictures, no matter what I do,
you can see the whites of my scalp.
So I don't take photos and cause I don't take photos.
I don't have anything to post and because I don't have anything to post,
I don't see a point in opening the app. Plus I'd rather spend my time reading.
Well, I used to be more, um, meek and mild. I was just like, Oh no,
they're going to comment. I'm oddly. And they're going to hate on me. But then,
um, the one tick talks started blowing up.
One of my videos blew up and I was just like, Hey, they don't hate me.
And I was just like, Oh, okay. The confidence that's coming in.
And I get a hundred notifications a day from my best friend saying,
I found this new video you would love and I'll click on it occasionally.
And I love the video cause it's funny,
it's short and it like matches my personality,
but it makes me really upset when like I faced him with my friend and she's
scrolling through tech talk.
It's really scary to see my friends kind of disconnect with me and just connect
with these people. They've never met
That were narcs and that we kind of hate social media.
Like parents hate social media.
I don't think they really know our stories and know why exactly we don't want to
exist on the platforms and the way that they are.
I've had hurtful things posted about me. And the thing about the internet it's,
it's there forever and it's not like a word that was just said to me on the
playground. It's something that's out there and other people can see.
Okay.
There can be communities found within social media,
but my personal experience with it and from a lot of stories that I've heard
through logoff is that a lot of kids have lost people because of social media.
And I think that that constant mindless scrolling allows you to kind of go into
this bubble and just hunker down and to not really talk with people.
I know a bunch of kids that like.
Don't know how to communicate outside of like an emoji or like outside of like a
picture,
like only have one picture face and like will repeatedly take the same black.
We'll stop everyone in the friend group to pick a wall and just sit there and
pose and take a hundred photos and stand there and wait, it doesn't matter.
I'll take one more.
I definitely like would base like entire friend groups to hang out and just take
pictures. Like we wouldn't communicate,
it would just be pictures just to post on Instagram.
And then I would find myself that like,
we didn't even connect when we were hanging out.
It wasn't quality time because I feel like, Oh,
I have to get that perfect photo of all of us,
all of us looking like we're having fun. Even if we're not,
I just need to get that so I can post it.
After a while you feel the pressure and everything,
people start being people and they're just empty profile pictures.
People will come to me and they won't know my name.
They'll go by my screen name. And then I'm just like, am I human?
I like to ask questions in comments and ask like, Oh, where'd you get that?
Or you know, like what hair dye did you use? Or something like that.
Because I think it's a lot more engaging or I like to remember, I'll make my,
like my posts I'll make it a question.
Like the caption I like to interact with like a lot of my followers through
comments because I'm uncomfortable, you know, messaging them personally.
It's good to like interact with the people that support you. Yeah.
But what would you say to like bigger influencers? Like Kylie Jenner,
like Kim Kardashian that camp and have that interaction via the comments.
Yeah. And then Alex, some people just don't even reply to those.
Just double tap, like the message.
Going off, what you said about like making real human connection.
And now have you ever like looked into like social media accounts that like
promote that? Cause I don't know if you guys know, we're not really strangers.
If you guys know them, they have a card game, you know now. Okay.
So it's basically a card game where you have perception analysis and then
reflection and then you just have conversation, like how are you really? Or,
you know, if it has like what's what do you,
what would you name the chapter of this in your life? And then boom,
we're in a 20 minute conversation that like,
she feels really low and she's trying to change. And the, you know,
when I would have never thought that if this social media account didn't push me
or did it and encourage me to have deeper conversations, I agree.
But I think the issue is with the algorithm in place.
Like that's not popping up on my feed. Like I'm not,
I don't know that those exist and because it's so expansive and because there's
so much hollowness in mindless scrolling,
like I've never found that if I found that I would have loved that with the
algorithm and the fact that you never see those things that I always feel like
we're on a whole different side of tick-tock than you are.
And all it takes is just to look up like deep conversations on the internet.
There would have been a Vogue article about we're not really friends and then
you would have looked it up, you know? So in order to change your algorithm,
you just have to change the things that you're looking for.
Don't you think maybe like the algorithm in place is what's making it so
dangerous. Cause it's like,
they're pumping out these really terrible kind of like content videos,
but also you've got like the attention economy where they're like fighting to
get your information, to then give to people, to like,
to put ads in your feed that you won't notice.
If you're not on social media, you know, it's going to do that anyway.
Like if you're searching anything up,
like if you're searching something up on Safari and you go onto your computer
onto Chrome, the ads would probably be the same.
Just the internet technology. Yeah.
Um, I sat down here saying that social media makes people antisocial,
but hearing Alexa and Alex speak it makes me remember that, um, social media,
isn't just, you know, the whole tick-tock scene. It's also schools,
there's clubs and stuff. Um,
I've made a couple of new friends from social media because um,
they live in Ventura. I live in San Diego.
So I don't think it's necessarily just the whole big fame thing.
There's also the smaller group. Yeah.
I'd like to say social media changed my life. I'm I'm more confident.
I actually think about what I wear. I used to just roll out bed,
grab what's near. I do see how social media can be bad,
but I like to think of it in a positive light.
Okay.
I know you guys remember like those musically days,
I feel like that was my biggest bullying because it's like, when you're,
it's just like entering a whole different society,
it's just like we are going on. You're making videos.
You don't really know what you want to post or what you want to do or what you
want to look like.
So it is going to be cringy at first and it's not going to be great musically.
Definitely a dark time. Um,
more recently I did have a hate account on Instagram. They, um,
like told me to kill myself and told me that like,
cause I was upset about my pet dying that I should kill myself and that I like
was ugly and I looked like a clown and yeah, I really, really,
really let it get to me for a long time. But then I realized, you know,
like they're only making fun of me because I'm giving them attention about it.
So I just had to like block them from all my accounts and block all the people
they were following and block all the people that were following them.
And then I just had to stop looking. And if I don't look at it,
then I don't know what they saying.
Right. And that's the thing. It's just like, once you stop looking into it,
it's you just stop beating the fire and it will die eventually because you just
don't even pay it. No mind. I don't have a big following.
So it's basically mostly people. I know,
usually it's tech talks and it's not with my name in it,
but you can tell that it's implied towards me. And I try not to comment,
but like there's some points where they're coming out and saying like completely
false things about me posting and hating on someone through the internet is
completely different from in-person because it's there forever.
You don't have control over that because it's up to them to delete it.
So I have had rude comments been made about me,
but I've never been like heavily cyber bullied because I don't really have a big
following. And because of the community that I'm in,
I've just read hundreds of stories about kids who like,
felt like they wanted to kill themselves because of the rude comments they were
getting. And I just remember,
like there were nights when I would cry and I'd be so upset because I couldn't
really do anything about it.
My cyber bullying experience the first like big one, I.
Was in like this like dance team. Right. And I was the shortest kid,
the fattest kid and like one of like three Asians.
So I clearly stuck out no matter what I did. And you know, like after practice,
like all the girls would like do that like 2014, like out,
like the duck face thing pose one day,
like one of them like invited me to take the photo with them.
And I thought like, this was the only way you could pose on Instagram.
So like I did it and then they took the photo and they were all like laughing
and they started uploading it. I didn't know why over,
like the next two and a half,
three years they would continuously like bring me into the photo.
Like I would never just go up. They'd always ask me, Hey,
do you wanna be in the photo? You wanna be in the photo?
So I felt like I was being included,
but when I like got a phone and when I got an Instagram and when I started
following like my fellow dance team members, I would look at their Instagrams.
And like, from the beginning it's photos of me, they'll zoom in on me.
And they'll be like, look at that fat thing, that gay monster, like,
is it trying to pose? Like, what is like, what does that thing think?
It is like, do they think they're cute? I wasn't like in elementary school,
like, I don't know how to deal with myself.
Like I barely know how to open a peanut butter jar.
And you expect me to know how to deal with people,
calling me it and like a monster. You know what I mean?
Instagram, tic talk. Everything is the highlight reel my Instagram.
I'm not going to post the ugliest picture of me when I scroll through my
friends. I, in the back of my head, I should know that,
but that's the same for them yet. I'm like, they look so pretty.
Why do I not look like that? And I think for younger generations,
it's really scary that they're going to have to do.
I have this one photo. That's so vivid in my memory. And like,
I'm at like an aquarium and I'm leaning against like one of the fish tanks and
my dad and my dad and my brother next to me.
And I'm like half of my brother's height by face sagging my
body. Like my clothes don't fit on me. And I'm like,
at the time I didn't realize how depressed I wasn't home, how much these,
like these like dance photos were ruining me.
That's kind of when I knew like social media is not something I like,
I'm not safe here. You know?
And so an excuse I can make for not pleasing people online is that I don't use
it. And then I'll be okay.
The, the bad thing about social media is like,
if you have a bad friend in real life and your mom's like avoid them,
don't be nice to them and stuff. But on social media,
you almost can't avoid them. And I feel like that's where like a lot,
a lot of kids can get hurt because they comment rude things on your things,
or they don't share the same opinions. And those friends are horrible. You know.
I don't know how Tumblr is now because I don't go on it.
But there are a lot of like self-harm pages and eating disorder pages with like
ideas to make yourself lose weight.
There's so much of that on Tumblr that I had to get off of tumbler. Um,
and I think that definitely will hurt kids now. And in the future.
I just couldn't imagine being like 10 or 11 or 12,
just being so young and looking through this and taking all these suggestions in
I'm 18 now. Like I go through it and I know better,
but I feel like you could get seriously hurt when you're young,
because you really just don't know any better.
Yeah.
I'll just play back on what you said about how little kids don't know better.
I hack where it was.
Like scoop ice cream and then it said microwave, the spoon,
most children wouldn't know. Yeah. In cases like that,
it does hurt me to be pro social media, but social media,
I think it was always more intended for more discretion.
Like I, I have this friend named Jesse Page and she is very,
very like pro body positivity and like pro like, like mental health, you know,
like really like, I want to get better.
That's why I keep all my posts up because I want people to be able to go back
and look, I wasn't on T for three years, you know, when I was out, you know,
like I was fully out and like fighting for myself to start hormones, my friend,
Jesse too. She also puts before and after she always puts like,
this is the real me a hundred percent.
I don't think I would be the person I am. If it wasn't for social media,
I first came out on tech talk and my parents didn't even know that's how they
found out, actually.
Yeah.
Well, um,
it's kind of funny because I talked to a lot of organizations with logoff and
the main point that they try to get across is that they're trying to advocate
for kids to get cell phones and technology and social media at an older age. Um,
and you know, years ago I would've said that's really stupid.
That's like the drug talk, like don't do drugs, don't be on social media.
I'm not going to listen to that.
But then after years of kind of self-reflection, I wish someone would have said,
you don't need Instagram to have a social life.
If I go back to like my 13 year old self and like,
I didn't have all the experiences I had and I just kinda knew like, Oh,
it's a good place. I would be posting. God knows what. So yeah, kids are dumb.
And if you give kids a platform to do whatever they want,
they're going to be dumb.
There's no educational advocacy out there to actually allow for that to happen.
And when they are there, it's this older teacher who like,
has a completely different outlook on social media because they never existed in
an age where it was your life. You know, I just feel like it's almost,
it's just unrealistic when I was 13, I was fully on social media,
making videos every single day. So I just feel like if anything,
it helped me more when I was 13. Like,
it really allowed me to just know what things were and not be.
So what is going on? Like, you know, not knowing a lot of things.
Because like I was on social media at like 11 years old,
like I was a child and on social media and my, my dad told me he was like,
you know, but you're also trans. And you're also like LGBT, you know,
you need to be able to meet people because your bubble that you would know of
trans people would be zero.
Here's the thing. I think we're underestimating children. They're relentless.
And we put an age limit on Instagram or an age limit on like an adult type
website. They're still going to get through.
I didn't have social media.
I was probably like the last couple people out of my like friends,
because my mom knew the restrictions and how the things that are on the internet
is you can't control what other people are posting and you can't control what
your kids are seeing.
But I believe that like other kids mature at different ages and we can't really
like restrict certain people going on this platform when it's public,
it's difficult. Cause I,
I do think what you said is true where if I was 13 and
someone said you have to be 13 to get on this app or like, you have to be older.
I would have lied about my age, my age.
And I know there are millions of kids like that that are like, he, he,
he break the system and be like put in a different age. Okay.
See, that's the thing with any problem,
you can't just take the problem and move it over here.
It's all about the education. It should be a class like how sex ed is.
There should be like tech ed.
Pewter lab days exist. Like, was that just my school?
Like there were computer lab days or something. Yeah.
Where we just practice right now you practice typing. Well,
instead of just practicing typing practice, how to not be an idiot online.
And like how to like learn and understand like the harm of it. Because like,
if I had that education, I know that like I would have like,
at least braced myself for it. Once COVID kind of hit,
I realized like I need social media or else.
I can't like find anyone. I know some people that kind of think,
like when I say that I don't use social media a lot. They're like, Oh,
do you think you're cooler than us?
Cause you don't need like social media validation,
but it's more like I'm afraid of if I search for that validation that
I'm not going to get it.
I know all schools,
they don't talk about some deep topics that social media brings slight and it
teaches you and it teaches you how to get through it and how to do it without
talking to your family, if you are uncomfortable.
And without talking to the school,
because sometimes schools don't have that education in place.
My teacher told everyone that RuPaul's drag race was a good example of trans
people. Of course, like I got in trouble for like correcting him or whatever,
but it was like,
I could not let him spread fake information like that because those are not
trans people. Those are drag Queens. And that is a totally different topic.
I'm very far in my transition for 16 and it,
social media definitely helped me a lot.
Yeah.
And then the fact that you even got in trouble for that shows that school is
that like, you know, they're lacking.
You know, personal experience is how you learn the most. You know,
you go on social media and there's someone talking about this eating disorder,
this depression that they went to,
it's just someone actually talking to a camera,
giving you real advice at a school really can never do.
I want to preface it with, I am kind of like, I'm very lucky. Um,
the school that I go to Altima,
it's like a private school in Alabama and they're very,
very good with kind of integrating these conversations into the academic
dialogue. I totally agree with everything you all have said,
I've learned how to rainbow loom and I've done a bunch of different things on
social media,
but I've also looked up like election and there has been misinformation after
misinformation and with COVID. So for y'all that answered, how do you,
how do you kind of outweigh like the chance to learn a bunch of new things with
also the chance of seeing a lot of stuff that isn't necessarily true?
I think you just have to look for credible websites. I mean,
it's just like when you're doing an essay, you wouldn't believe, uh,
I'm just feel like blogs, any of that kind of stuff.
It is easy to get a lot of misinformation,
but it's also easy to see that this information is fake. Like,
but what about like a young kid that can't really discern that.
My dad actually, um,
put the Washington post and the New York times on my phone so that I would look
at it more so I would get the notifications, you know,
all I had to do with put it on my phone.
Been times when I've disagreed with what the teacher said and that that is true.
But I also think that with social media, with the algorithm in place,
it's harder to, harder to discern.
I disagree with you just because I feel like as kids,
we look up to our teachers for the right answers.
And if they are like providing like a bias answer,
we're getting the wrong information. Yeah.
If you've taken a political science class,
there will be times where the teacher's own political beliefs might make the
learning bias. So comparable to social media, it's about the same.
I think it's more dangerous on social media because I agree it is very dangerous
in the classroom. Especially when you look up to teachers with the algorithm,
they don't have that humanity for, to like, to actually discern like, Oh,
this is an article about how Macs aren't important. So like,
but I'm going to pump that out. But I would just say this,
I would just say exact reason because,
because it's just one human one way of life, one perspective, one thought,
you know, but at least when you go on social media and you put up Trump,
it's going to come up both sides of the story, you know,
and it's up to you to differentiate and read it and see, okay,
this comes from this credible website and this is coming from a blog on
Wikipedia.
What if we're talking about like, just a straight forward thing, like math,
science, or English,
sometimes you can get like a cruddy teacher and they won't really teach you
that. Well, it's just type that in social media lowering it.
Like I've never actually been held by a math teacher. I mean,
photo math was the only thing that helped me. I mean, it's not even like,
it only gave me the answers. I mean, you sweat,
like you scrolled up and it really showed you step by step what it does.
And you look for the reasoning. Here's the reason. Yeah.
And sometimes if I have a lot of trouble with like an assignment or something,
I'll actually like post a picture of it and I'll be like, Hey,
like I am really bad in this subject.
Every single time people do message me and help me out.
Or like will comment and be like, Hey,
like actually this is what you're doing wrong. And this is how you do it. Right.
No.
For me on a macro scale, I think there are some really, um,
troubling signs that social media is kind of unwinding society and humanity
in the sense of like the democracy debate,
governments can use social media to then kind of undermine elections. Um,
and I think those are bigger issues when you look at the macro scale, but again,
on the micro scale,
there are so many different people in the world that dive with it.
I know other people that are like me,
I think I would thrive more without social media because I kind of,
I compare myself and I look for those likes and look for those comments on my
posts. And I feel like if I didn't have that concern,
my mental health and my self love and self image would be so much better if I
didn't see all this stuff on the internet.
Part of me wants to ask for like a diff a definition for like thrive.
Cause like, are we talking about like us.
Human race or like people individually.
Instagram and things who might put like, you make,
you have poor body image and this, that, but also in the case of like Alex.
You know, it helps him, you know,
meet other trans people and understand that like he isn't alone. Right.
And so it's such a general question with so many variables that like,
you can't just like put one answer down it's so case by case,
you need to know if it's on the micro macro scale. And you know,
like Alex has a following that is a lot of other trans kids are looking for
other trans kids. And if Alex was one Mia for a month, people would panic,
you know? And like, you know, like, I can totally like,
sorry to like keep using you. But like, like this is like the easiest, like,
like analogy, right. I'm sorry, Alex.
Just like the easiest example.
Um, I have a question actually. Um, so I, in the recent months,
especially there have been a lot of protests and stuff that were like,
a lot of them were created online.
And I think that if we didn't have social media,
a lot of them wouldn't have been possible because there wouldn't have been the
word spread so fast.
I agree. Yes. These protests got really big and it's really important. But I,
the thing that I've kind of been looking at is the people that go and take a
picture. I'm like, Oh my God, like I'm so supportive. And like,
they change their profile picture. They do the blackout Tuesday.
And then a week later it gets archived.
When people go with like professional grade cameras and like bring a hair and
makeup team to like sit there and like pose the middle of the street.
Like it's less of the movement and more of the social media.
And yeah.
And I think that's also a perspective thing because I think there was maybe one
or two major influencers who were dumb enough to take a production team out
there to take a picture.
And I think that was for people like you guys were anti-social media focused,
be like, wow, let's see. Look at all these influencers.
It's the whole avatar community is just like them.
And I was in New York for a couple of days and I was in like Washington square
or something. They were passing out flyers. They're like, Hey,
share this on your Snapchat. If you know anyone in New York. And I,
wasn't only in New York for like two days, but I posted it and I got like,
I don't know, like 40,000 people on Snapchat to watch it and be,
and if they were in New York, they could go by.
And he's like, performative parts. I'm not talking only influencers. Like, yes,
that is a big part.
And it is very troublesome when influencers do like kind of go out and like pose
for like the picture rather than, than for the protest.
But when people are kind of seeing like, Oh, this is trendy.
And when people have that desire to like go viral,
they'll go out and they'll do it.
Here's like a scenario. What if I'm me, Alex? I mean, Alex, Alex and I,
we all just teamed up. We did like a charity stream and then donated to,
let's say, let's, let's just throw back to like early 2020,
where there was like fires wouldn't California or Australia
thrive from us donating.
I do agree that, um,
social media does like promote awareness and it helps change indefinitely in our
societies. Everyone's on social media. So if they see this and it gets spread,
it's going to make change. Yeah.
And that's kind of why I made like the logoff movement is because I saw that
there was this multifaceted nature about social media and I at least just wanted
to discuss it with teens and to be like,
let's figure out how to exist in a healthier way. And, um,
even though social media, we can talk about the good and bad all day.
It's just nice to be in one space and have one column.
I mean, yeah. Technically social media did bring us here.
So I guess that's like a thing.
Hey, we don't have to talk about that.
Hi, everyone Bashir very happy new year and hope you enjoy this episode.
I personally struggled a lot with my social media usage.
So recently I bought an alarm clock so that the phone is not the first thing I
look at in the morning. And I'm not tempted to go on social media.
If you have any suggestions as to how you control your social media usage,
feel free to leave in the comment section below. And thanks for watching.